рішення Ради національної безпеки і
оборони про невідкладні заходи із
забезпечення економічної безпеки на
період дії правового режиму воєнного
стану я говорила сьогодні з юристами які
сказали що насправді це явка з повинною
це свідчить про те що закон в Україні не
працює і
насправді ті хто готував навіть цей
документ мали усвідомлювати Що принесе
даний документ і як він буде оціне
саме юристами і
правниками так Точно не можна замінити
цими змістовними зустрічами за
ініціативи Генерального прокурора
виконання законів тому що після цього
рішення був круглий стіл де нібито знову
намагалися врегулювати в ручному режимі
якісь питання І знову пообіцяти щось
бізнесу чому ми продемонстрували всі
слайди і ви Петро Олексійович досить
детально розповіли тому що вся
пропозиція яка зараз була вам
представлена вона побудована на якісній
зміні і необхідній зміні роботи бюро
економічної безпеки це тим чим ми жили
по будучи у владі це те що має країна
обов'язково виконати для того щоби не
всі правоохоронні органи здійснювали
перевірки і приходили до бізнесу а
справді працював один єдиний орган тобто
пройшло 5ть років ми повертаємося знову
до цього ж самого питання незважаючи на
те що цей орган створений він почав
працювати але він працює як говорить
переважна більшість бізнесу ще гірше чим
податкова міліція в часів Януковича
Клименка Ну Це звісно означає що ті
першочергові Заходи які запропоновані на
всіх інших слайдах зможуть спрацьовувати
тільки тіки тоді коли ми якісно
відреформуємо бюро економічної безпеки і
це перший крок який наша країна має
зробити і і те що маємо в перший день
засідання парламенту приймати вже
підготовлені зміни для того щоби справді
пере провести конкурсний відбір
керівництва з залученням іноземних
спеціалістів які не дадуть можливості
знову знайти свого який буде виконувати
ту ж саму роботу що й виконувалися ці
роки і керівників департаментів які
також мають пройти через такий високий
конкурсний відбір щодо решти працівників
насправді вони мають проходити
зараз такий собі
кваліфікаційний від перегляд чи оцінку в
з ну комісією і громадською радою яка
має працювати в цьому органі Це нам
дасть можливість насправді очиститися
від великої кількості працівників які
просто перекочувались із СБУ з
податкової міліції серед них можливо є
спеціалісти але вони мають
продемонструвати це через пройти через
ці Жернова для того щоби довести що вони
відповідають професійним вимогам які
пред'являються до новоствореного органу
і Насправді це дуже важливий момент який
після чого потрібно далі змінювати
роботу бюро еномічної безпеки і в чому
вона має полягати коли запрацюють всі
інші пропозиції які ми запропонували
звісно ми будували свою роботу про те що
підслідність беб виняткова виключна вони
займаються економічними злочинами Вони
мають бути єдиними в країні для цього
звісно ми маємо розуміти а як може
побудована їх робота будь і тут
включається те що всі звикли говорити що
це аналітичний орган який має володіти
великою кількісті інформацією А що це
таке це спеціальні алгоритми роботи
побудовані на ризикоорієнтованому
підході І абсолютно точно що
е до здійснення будь яких дій має ними
проведена бути велика робота навіть до
початку
реєстрації в єдиному реєстрі досудових
розслідувань тобто до відкриття
кримінального провадження беб має
зібрати достатньо доказів і інформації і
не діяти просто так на обум а можливо
там щось в ході розслідування вискочить
і тоді не треба буде проводити обшуки як
зараз проводяться з приходять на
підприємство вивертають все зі столів
керівництва е менеджерів підприємства
для того щоби щось знайти ні при зміні
роботи якщо і будуть до дозволені такі
обшуки то це буде предметом до пошуку
доказів чи виїмки доказів щодо
здійснення певних правопорушень не мо
Оце те що ми називаємо маски-шоу
маске-шоу - це коли забігли і говорять
всім лягти і вигрібають все зі столів і
на столах і всю техніку забирають Ну ми
повернулися до
2013 року це точно Ви сказали тому що з
цим боротися насправді важко
перебудувати роботу правоохоронців важко
но ми ж змогли це зробити і зараз так
швидко поламали роботу яка
налагоджувалася яка була спрямована на
розуміння і на
дуже інтелігентного не знаю дружнього
відношення до бізнесу бізнес і держава -
це дві сторони які тримають взагалі весь
державний устрій тому коли ми говоримо
що як має бути зміна інституці ціональна
зміна роботи беп то вона
має Вони мають запровадити єдину
унікальну
методологію яка забезпечує економічну
безпеку яка якою користується беб
податкова і митниця тому що це три
органи які залишаться в роботі з
платниками податків і цю методику має
знайте бізнес не треба нічого ховати від
бізнесу не треба робити такі заходи щоб
потім ось ми щось розробили щоб ударити
в спину бізнесу бізнес партнер держави і
тому мені здається що
якщо нас підтримують з тими ініціативами
які тільки що продемонстрував Петро
Олексійович то насправді ми будемо тоді
всі сили докладати щоби далі рухатися по
шляху подальших змін саме інституційних
змін які потрібні для роботи бюро
економічної безпеки тільки тоді ми
будемо говорити що щось буде змінюватися
і Тому ніякі зустрічі додаткові ніякі
вирішення от знову створити Раду бізнесу
при на якісь там площадці Скажіть будь
ласка ну яки
інвестняню на тих хто гасить Інвест
пожежу на Інвест пожежників але має
захищати закон а ж ні в якому ні разі
Інвест Яні
інвестпожежники ради підприємстві або
Шульга там чи Шурма чи як його там з
рештою Тобто це механізм має працювати
інституційний інакше бізнес сюди не
прийде Я Хочу
наголосити одну дуже важливу
позицію Україна може профінансована бути
партнерами за рахунок коштів публічних
фінансів тобто бюджетів наших країн
партне патнерів великої сінки євросоюза
Сполучених Штатів лише на
20%. 80%
це абсолютно чітка оцінка наших
партнерів мають бути прямі іноземні
інвестиції з таким іноземни з таким
інвестиційним кліматом не прийде ніхто
бо це підрив довіри довіри до
української влади довіри до силовиків
яки її зараз немає і головне довіри до
нашої держави а от цього ми допустити аж
ніяк не
можемо Я хотіла би все ж таки
підкреслити що можливо такі площадки
Де присутні представники як рада бізнесу
це якісь консультаційні розмови поради
напрацювання на майбутнє але точно це не
вирішення величезних проблем які на
сьогодні є в нашому суспільстві щодо
тиску на бізнес і тому тому абсолютно
точно Я закликаю просто всіх силовиків
набратися сили волі і всупереч всьому
виконувати І на сьогодні діючі норми
кримінального процесуального кодексу
тому що все що тут було запропоновано
тільки їх посилює вдвічі втричі Хоча я
якби у нас працювала і була правова
держава То того що є на сьогоднішення
безпеки Це просто наве Да уже того би не
склада
тому вибачте як робити
аудит вжитих за обмежувальних захів
заходів у кримінальних провадженнях як
визначити інформацію яку треба там або
коло питань які треба
призупинити слухайте це означає що
Україна як посилювати беб Тото вони
вважають що беб у нас зараз слабкий і
відповідно до рішен Ради його треба
посилювати Це точно дорога
в неправильному напрямку це якщо
вчитатися в слова які написані в цьому
рішенні Саме так і означає тут якраз
приділено зовсім мало уваги бізнесу А
якщо чесно то зовсім нічого тому наші
пропозиції - це насправді дія а дія
призведе до результату а не розмови так
і будемо рухатися Слава Україні Героям
слава Героям слава